sometimes you know when like sometimes a
guys square up against each other and
shoving kind of starts but it's really
just to kind of like Flex and not to
actually start the fight yeah that oh
but you know with your push she's gonna
fall down and Tumble right that's Geo's
push my push I might go like this and I
might fly back into the locker and it'll
close on me
[Music]
all right so you guys saw what happened
with Dana White over uh news is there a
video oh you want to see that I do want
to see the video you like seeing
violence towards women what the [__] is
that what that is I thought we were
talking you didn't get caught oh I don't
know I didn't watch it
I've been reading about all over the
place I don't even know what's going on
so I'm not saying that's not my husband
I'm just saying I thought he was slapped
there right yeah yeah they know why I
slapped the girl she saw she slapped in
first right yeah she slapped him first
and then he which makes it okay does it
I think so I don't know so uh I think so
I don't know I believe in equality yeah
do we believe in equality or not depends
if we believe believe in equality here
it is just in case is he kissing oh
there's anything ready right here what
do you think they're fighting about
and then she's the one who hits him
first oh wow oh [__]
oh no the second one is too much to say
oh no she went again oh well there's
more but she slapped them back wait can
I see more wait she's left him back yeah
what do you mean he went okay so she
went like that and then he went like
that and then and then he went like that
again and then she swung at him again so
like they just
watch she goes boom and then he goes
boom and then he'll go again watch both
again huh oh okay no she caught her hand
who is someone else hitting her
I think so there's a person in the back
no there's a there's a person in the
back I thought that when she went down
he went like this he just doubles
whatever Dana White does what's the
morals of society now though because if
we believe in equality then it's just I
think the moment the Dana White hit
slaps his wife Herb Dean should be like
yeah you know I think it's always pretty
situational I think everybody likes to
say that uh it's equal and then they
wait and see who does it and if it's
someone like Dana White then all of a
sudden it's wrong again yeah because the
way that Ivan because I didn't see the
video but the way it's been everywhere
it's like Dana White slaps his wife
whatever right but she slapped him yeah
then you watch the video like wait she
slapped him first though right so what
are is it equality or is it just guys
can't touch girls like what's the second
let's say there's no equality bar the
world that you want yeah the guys can't
touch let's say that's not perfect yeah
if it's not if we're if we're not trying
to fight for the equality then guys
shouldn't touch girls but girls can slap
cars yeah if that's the if that's the
because Bart believes in inequality yeah
if it's inequality and that's what I
believe in okay yeah but there's also no
biological difference in the slap
between men and women right there's not
well only the belief that women were
raised which is that they're weaker than
men physically but they're not but
they're not Dana White is for sure
stronger than his wife his arm looks way
huge compared to hers but they say don't
judge a book by its cover it's not about
look that's something else they've been
saying that the other thing too is the
hidden inner strength of women is
actually really really powerful but it
starts from right here and right here
sure have you seen a mom trying to save
a baby from a car exactly she she throws
the car she picks up the car over her
head she throws it
the city bus she picked it right up
overhead and just put it aside her name
is Wonder Woman that's one thing that
I'm like it's always it's because it's
Dana White it's convenient yeah I don't
want to yeah press on too much but isn't
there something about his slap thing uh
like it's too hard no yeah that is that
is it was a large retaliate no no no no
no no no oh the new slap leak he bought
the slap Lee yeah did he buy it so is
this just really brilliant marketing
that we don't know yet that's a lot of
the story lines are a lot of storylines
yeah that they're like oh it's to
promote his new slap lead yeah so his
slap league on TBS got uh it got
postponed the debut of it because of
this incident if that is connected in
conjunction with like a but I mean like
when you're saying when you're saying oh
like but it's Dana White but does it
does that mean it's like on brand I mean
the people just bought slap League like
who the [__] buys a slap League who
starts that in America you know you know
what I mean it is funny to delay it by
one week look out of sensitivity
situation for seven days we're in delay
and then kick it off next Tuesday that's
like saying like hey uh we didn't get
enough uh ticket sales to this event
let's um let's uh push it back
I think it's also because so here's his
quote on what he said he said uh you've
heard me say it over the years there was
never ever an excuse for a guy to put
hands on a woman I'm literally making no
excuses for this thing at all it's never
happened before it's the first time it's
happened people are gonna say what
they're gonna say and it is what it is
whatever people say I deserved I deserve
it yeah he doesn't believe in inequality
at all
no he believes in it so wait wait just
to be clear if if a woman sucks you in
the face
you it's it's open season it depends on
how much it hurts is she my wife yes if
it hurts real bad yeah oh [__] it's a
random it's a random chick out of Bodega
okay and does she like does she like
work like is she like Colleen clink who
would knock me out yeah no she's not
like Colleen she's just like but you
know what I'm saying like when does the
conversation like where does it get you
can't just say guy and women in your
case I agree because I think most tricks
could knock you out but picture picture
like this ask your sister ask your
sister about the Lee all right ask her
about the lead my sister's titties and
knock you out dude and they have
no um there's Suffocation I picture it
like this how dare you I picture like
this that's my sister you're throwing a
rocket in an Apache helicopter yeah you
know what I mean and then the Apache
helicopter gets to fire back at you it's
a weakness like it's it's kind of like
nah all right but all I'm saying is yeah
yeah I get into argument with Ronda
Rousey and she starts [__] me up I'm
fighting for my life but she's the
Apache helicopter in this and I am
fighting for my life you know what I
mean but that's like she's like a
trained fighter and [__] yeah but then
that's what I mean by like that's what
in most cases though in most cases
yeah it's I I'm the Apache helicopter I
just I just take it avoiding avoiding
Overkill like that let's just say it's a
woman that weighs more than you
oh so you got something out against fat
girl she may not you might it might be
muscle so it's open season on she might
have a backpack full of eyes
because when you think fairness in a
fight you have to weigh Fighters so
let's say This Woman's just having she
got the height she got the reach and she
got the weight and she's like coming in
and just gives you good ones am I
allowed to run is running an option is
running an option or do I just have to
man up and not well it's too late she
already hit you once and she's gonna do
it again what do you do so I can run
still I grab her hands I grab her wrist
She's Got You cornered damn it Ryan why
you gotta make so wild I'm fighting for
my life bro dude yeah if my actual life
is in danger not my pride it's not my
pride it's my actual she's not gonna
kill you she just wants to beat you up
yeah she won't see yeah she wants social
media yes are there cameras out
someone's going live you won't die but
there will be visible marks and people
will make fun of you are there cameras
out recording the incident how do you
know you're in the middle of a fight
you're gonna look around I don't know
it's hypothetical I'm just trying to
figure out my evidence don't be
concerned about that it's just down to
your morality all I'm saying is
I also think if you're Dana White you
know people are taking all the time I
think I think I'll do one of those High
School shoves
we're a high school show a high school
show because what's the high school show
sometimes it's a high school
that's what happened to me I'm saying
with me it's different what's your high
school sometimes you know when like
sometimes a guys square up against each
other and shoving kind of starts but
it's really just to kind of like Flex
and not to actually start the fight yeah
that oh but you know with your push
she's gonna fall down and Tumble right
that's Geo's push my push I might go
like this and I might fly back into the
locker and it'll close on me
you're out of the situation
I don't write the rules on physics here
the Apache helicopter things are pretty
good analogy yeah I think so yeah that's
how I feel because I believe in
inequality and that's what I wouldn't
hit a [__] back up JK men believe in
inequality like like to be fair and the
only reason why this is actually like a
a more serious thing than it needs to be
is uh like for example my older sister
when I was like a young brat shoot hit
me and that would just be how it was
like you would get hit and then there
was never hit her back no really
because kids is different yeah kids is a
fair game I think I would I think I got
owned when I was smaller than her
regardless or if she would tell my
parents I would get [__] destroyed
yeah yeah so like there was no point in
hitting her back but when I got same
sizes her I remember we were [__] my
parents dry cleaners one day and she
like slapped me in the face for
something but I was like like probably
like an inch or two taller than her so I
finally like took her by the shoulder
with one hand and I just pushed her and
she came back at me she slapped me one
more time and then I just [__] pushed
her again and then after that she just
never hit me again because that push was
probably hard because she finally fell
into the clothes it was just it was just
a matter of understanding it's like a
demonstration of strength it wasn't like
I'm I'm hurting you it was just like I'm
gonna take your slab and push you you
can slap me I don't give a [__] and I'll
push you did you did she push her and
then she fly into a [__] dryer thing
and it closed on her
[Laughter]
barbell he uh he said like um his sister
his sister framed him for something with
his parents and so he he got in trouble
so he confronted her and uh I think she
started to get violent and belligerent
with them and he was like [__] but she's
a girly so I [__] socked with my left
hand
[Music]
that's what I feel like is the thing
it's like when when a woman socks you in
the face or slaps you you're hitting
back more based on an emotional response
and not really like a physical it's also
sometimes it's a reaction for some
people it's like you're just mad I guess
if you really want to beat her up after
that but it's you're depends on what
kind of guy but then again though too
like if you're a girl and you hit
somebody you just have to expect no
matter what even it's right or wrong I
think you should still not hit people
not hit people yeah you know who it is
you know that there's people out there
that don't give a [__] if you're a girl
or not you know what I mean so you just
gotta come correct and make sure you
don't hit when you run into it when we
see videos of girls that feel like
they're [__] invincible and can do
anything or step up to like the biggest
deals just cause I also think like
that's not of course you're gonna get
deck like you know what I mean like you
can't do that gotta face a check it at
one like every once in a while have you
seen those videos on the internet of
like girls and like like it'll be like a
bar or something and they're like
picking fights because their man is
throwing down and they'll punch a dude
in the face and just one dude just decks
the chick because you don't give a [__]
like that [__] happens all the time so
it's like oh it's you hate to see it
right but it's like it's a reality that
you have to acknowledge yeah
it's nuts and we had all these crazy
Korean gangpei girls at like Sunny Hills
in high school or what right and they're
always the same [__] they would always
like girls are bigger at each other and
every single time the girls were about
to start fighting it was you could see
their boyfriends just hating the fact
that they had to throw fists now yeah
and it was never the girls that were
actually gonna get damaged Suddenly It's
just guys going in brawling getting
suspended bloody noses everything like
that and it's just it why did it start
it's always these two two tricks just
clapping at each other yeah it had
nothing to do with the guys you know how
come they don't fight
you must be careful brother you must be
careful they pull hairs they pull hair
like cuss really well yeah that's good
that's a good weapon to have in your
back bucket what happens in like so in
the military let's say you're squaring
off against a female soldier from the
other side do they train you to like not
have any kind of well what do you mean
like another country yeah they're not in
combat roles ever they're usually not
the USA is the only ones with females oh
really I didn't know I think Israel has
some when I was in there was Zero
females in infantry zero females in
combat roles but I think it has but I
mean that I was in I got it like 2009 so
things have changed now there's like
actual females and special laughs and
stuff yeah um so I mean it's dope for
them that they like have been able to
progress in that way but also I don't
know if other countries reciprocate that
oh I didn't even know that other
countries didn't do that I just saw
um really hot girls from other
militaries that are like I can be like
this but I could also be like oh like
get you a girl that can do both kind of
deal the cool tick tocks they might not
even they might not be combat rules
though it's really it's really military
I think has female combat role I think
so so what are they doing folding
laundry and [__] there's like a billion
other jobs
folding Linens for the military
making sandwiches for the military
that's [__] up I thought I think
that's sexist and that needs to change
thanks for pointing that out
[Laughter]